never before has the delivery been so
highly anticipated at the princess royal
hospital in hayward's heath
the astrazeneca vaccine is carefully
unpacked
and put in a fridge for storage but
hopefully
it won't be there for long in the race
between infections and
injections these jabs must be given out
quickly
and to increase vaccination rates
patients will receive
one dose their booster delayed for three
months
the guidance changed just at the end of
last week so we're just going to take a
little bit of time to review that and
we think there are some some groups that
may be extremely vulnerable that we
would want to vaccinate
in a slightly shorter time period but we
recognize that that extension to 12
weeks
allows us to get the initial vaccine to
more people and protect you know larger
parts of the community
with a new variant of the virus rapidly
spreading
the rollout is more urgent than ever but
will supplies
keep up with the demands of the
vaccination program
so far half a million people have been
vaccinated
but the target's two million a week an
army of vaccinators is needed
but red tape surrounding their training
is causing issues
from my perspective as a gp i think we
do need to
remove some of this bureaucracy i
completely understand that
we need to make sure that these people
are safe and are trained for the tasks
that they can
that they're actually doing so so
you can't remove all bureaucracy but the
the
the um we should minimize this and
and i will be having some high level
discussions to see how we can do this
there are questions too about delaying
the second dose of the pfizer vaccine
and for some the science is less
convincing
i mean it's a gamble it may be a gamble
that will pay off if we see
less hospital emissions but it may also
be
a risk because it does provide a
theoretical window for the virus to
potentially evolve and you're really
balancing
vaccinating twice the number of people
versus vaccinating
half that number there's doubt too
surrounding advice on mixing different
vaccines
it is all confusing for patients the
arrival of another vaccine though is
good news
the issue now delivering it quickly
enough to keep
up with the pandemic laura bundock sky
news